what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're going to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine today we're gonna
watch episode 12 and 13. back to back
auto play so you know what to do leave a
like on this video that'd be very much
appreciated at our patreon though
full-length Reaction watch alongs for
each of these episodes available there
all right guys let's see what's going on
with the benign
this installation is composed of
Constantine's accounts of the first
Punic War John Constantine what is going
on Captain ultimate just follow my lead
your theory is wrong the Greeks did not
climb out of the Trojan horse's butt put
this on Kevin Dr Einstein Professor
McGonagall why is me
but this card is get in it's for your
unprotected Kevin Professor student
she looked good damn Rosa killing the
game in that librarian outfit
[Music]
there's a well done plan hello Kevin
it's me Raymond Holt we need to get you
to safety your life is in danger
see as hell look it's my fault that
Murphy's after Kevin Captain Holt bailed
me out now it's my turn to bail him out
plus we've got this whole Tit for Tat
thing going and it's my time to tit it's
my tit turn my time to tit us today
Terry
still gonna be able to text and chat
with everyone it's not like I'm being
totally shut off from the outside world
don't you have a wedding you would think
they can push it no phone this is the
living room blinds will only be closed
at night if you must go into the living
room crawl on your belly observe
excellent form this is one of several
designated areas where you can stand
upright during the day so we have all
this room to work in your hand can be
seen from the living room window you
just killed Kevin Raymond I can't hear
you Kevin you're dead
how will you break the news to me wait
why are you here at this late hour and
whose blood is that okay I guess Kevin's
this is devastating I'm inconsolable and
I've killed myself
geez do you like Nick Cage movies
describe them okay well one of them is
the FBI has developed face swapping
technology not interested there's a
whole Plane full of convicts
oh my God I'm so glad Captain Hall
finally agreed to let you come visit I
missed you so much
is there a way we could get a bit more
privacy
just pretend I'm not here God knows I am
oh God it's not going to do anything for
Kevin chemist interesting keep going who
has to break into Alcatraz absolutely
not
are there no other actors
[Laughter]
you didn't ask for the password what if
I were an assassin or perhaps you
employed Face-Off technology what I
broke down and watched one of Peralta's
action films including one wearing a
man's head turns into a flaming skull
Ghost Rider yes my friend in the
organized crime unit tells me that
they're moving against Murphy tonight
we'll get a live feed of the raid and
have a viewing party Tie a Yellow Ribbon
Round the old oak tree because this boy
is coming home
I need to hear your voice tell me what
I've been missing at the 99 oh Terry's
grandma got really sick and had to spend
a month in the hospital how fun Scully
sat on a cherry pie and he didn't notice
for six hours the tin stayed on the
whole time now we're talking did you
take a picture honestly I didn't see it
I was at Terry's grandma's funeral
there's nobody here oh the house is
empty no no no no no no where's Sheamus
I don't understand what's happening
someone must have tipped him off the
raid is a bust and Murphy's still at
large your friend's crooked Sheamus's
girlfriend Nikki Works in a hair salon
in Beirut sends someone is a customer
get her to open up start gossiping send
me you can't go under cover you're not a
cop being a cop is a state of mind
I found the place that provides
shredding services for Murphy's
companies we could piece them together
smart how many shreds are we talking a
few oh my God
that's a job for the FBI it's great if
he's on the Run he probably won't be
worrying about Kevin and if you coach
yourself in chum and swim with sharks
you probably won't be eaten said they
have eaten Chum covered swimmer
Raymond I beg of you give me two hours
at the library to work on my book just
two hours it will make all the
difference yeah I could go with them
Sheamus's men could be lurking in the
stacks I find that unlikely I understand
but I disagree well then I hope it's
going to be proven right you'll have to
excuse me
agile Kevin you're the witness such a
vicious fight oh is that a fight you're
kidding he said you'll have to excuse me
instead of please excuse me might as
well spit my face
he did let him die gossips about her
love life then Nikki opens up about hers
I suck at gossiping Gina will be in your
ear feeding you stories Gina is
essential oh my God I love the earrings
where did you get those she's really
good at that
one time I was like so drunk and this
Meathead comes up to me and his body is
hot but his face is like okay so I'm
like why
I'm not gonna sleep with you just
because you promised to take me to
Bahamas take me to the Bahamas first and
then we'll see what happens okay
I guess we just grew apart when he went
to prison for life the guy I'm seeing is
into some shady stuff how'd you guys
meet that's a funny story the next time
you're all done oh my God figure out a
way to stay in that chair how do you
think I would look
as a blonde like Danielle Steel novel
oh good my orange is beginning to rot
have you seen what a bullet does to an
orange a shot of watermelon once it's
exactly what you want it to be
I'm simply trying to keep my husband
alive well you may not have a husband
when all of this is over you're not
gonna die Kevin
that's not what I meant
this is an absurd conversation and
you're being ridiculous
hop I can protect us we're going to the
library these these oranges are stepping
out oh damn it peeling out it was right
there
then hold has back-to-back meetings at
One Police Plaza today which means we
have a four-hour window before he checks
any of the security feeds
going out into public is a huge risk so
maybe let's go over some self-defense
techniques
wow it is key that you say something
cool afterwards like joke on that right
but they're not choking they're
experiencing Airway trauma better get
some corticosteroids to treat that
laryngeal
sick a dirt bag on the end a dirt bag is
a useful part of a vacuum the best way
to fit in is as Scholars weird perverts
yes weird perverts is far better yes
let's go
[Music]
the stashes or they get those disguises
Amy where'd you go down here I let the
pile take me even
hours and always
I'm really good at jigsaw puzzles I do
them all the time no offense Scully but
you can't be good or bad at jigsaw
puzzles it's uh no strategy or
e or logic
I got half a page
he is the one
he's the chosen cleared out as soon as
we got here even that actual pervert was
creeped out by us
I can feel your heat
perverts and assassin I've just gotten
so wrapped up in my research I've been
reading the most thrilling footnote
what was that I don't know
don't worry
I'll creep them right the hell out of
here do the creep oh do the creep oh Ben
you're dead and so is Kevin oh my God
it's just you you sort of track her into
my neck didn't you don't be stupid The
Trackers are in your shoes underwear and
wallet I also braided one into your hair
in my tangle no you could have cost him
his life what life Raymond I spend every
day lying on the floor of that house
talking with Jake about popular culture
do you know what it means to clap back
Raymond because I do
hey
yeah gorgeous
but finish what she was saying a weird
boyfriend
that is a story for next time we're so
close you can't
I want a perm big old perm
great idea yes
[Music]
foreign
really committed to that bit
[Music]
they are being followed
take a seat
oh I bet y'all feel bad I can't believe
someone took Raymond he had a gun Jake
it'll be okay we're gonna get him back
let me just call the 99 do you guys have
an Andy where Sheamus Murphy is we have
a huge problem yeah we all have huge
problems oh my God wowie apparently
Sheamus has been staying up in Rhinebeck
New York Scully
get dressed what
what go Scully go 82-21 Oak Ridge
Parkway copy that all right we're gonna
commandeer a car and then we're gonna
drive to Rhinebeck no one is gonna hurt
your husband
oh yeah
oh
follow me
spirit gum is a real killer so Sheamus
are you gonna kill me no don't be stupid
nothing like that I'm just gonna find
your husband bring him here slit his
throat in front of you then after you
watch him suffer kill you too oh it's
way better all right let's go what no
you're not coming in it's way too
dangerous for a civilian you're driving
back to the safe house he's got to pull
his best Nick Cage
hey there yes
yes I didn't take Kevin to the library
because I was Stir Crazy
it's because I didn't want you guys to
get divorced how is that any concern of
yours
been around so many failed marriages in
my life my mom and my dad and Charles
and Eleanor Hitchcock and Brandy
Hitchcock and Francine Hitchcock and
Brandy again Hitchcock and Madison
Madison wasn't his daughter but he
dropped her off at College last fall
I just couldn't stand to see you two
fall apart what do you have to say for
yourself the whole NYPD knows where you
are and they're coming for you right now
let's kill them both get out of here
before the cops come wait no no no no I
was lying about the backup I came alone
titled by sex tape
you're both gonna die now
yeah yeah Kevin yes
say it get some corticosteroids to treat
that laryngeal fracture sorry I couldn't
bring myself to call him a dirt bag and
why would you my Dirtbag is a very
useful part of the vacuum cleaner
it's all the same
except for that this perm saved your
life and I thank it for its service
Jesus thanks to our little operation the
FBI was able to roll up his entire
organization they're saying is going to
be one of the most significant Rico
prosecutions they've ever done amazing
wow
thank you for attending my dad well
thank you for tatting my tit
I'm gonna miss our little house yes and
in an even weirder way I think I might
actually miss you and in an even weirder
way I want you guys to be my dads that
is weirder yeah I got stuff
we never watched Captain Corelli's
mandolin say that to my face
there was a movie about Amanda Lynn and
you kept it from me for two months well
I didn't think it was any good it's just
some period piece is set in Greece oh my
God based on some dumb book
it has been a very trying time next
thing you're going to say you wish we
would watch Leaving Las Vegas the dark
ponderous reflection on alcoholism that
Erin cages Oscar ah
jeez
not a doctor sure
all right we're gonna watch the next one
now let's do this that was good that was
a good one
brother there was a batch beginning at a
jewelry store in Atlantic that just
turned into a hostage situation they
want you to be to negotiate my prayers
have finally been answered and prayed
for a hostage situation yes I did every
single day
the hostage take your ass for Jake by
name oh yes it's getting cooler oh man I
wonder who it is ooh maybe it's the
brother of someone I put away for Life
get down there and take Diaz with you
how do I look it doesn't matter let's go
negotiate dang this was my crime scene
before you bozos got here nice to meet
you too Dennis Get the Hell in there oh
it says negotiator on it
Judy that's another I guess and I'm
approaching the building
you wanted to talk away from like you
just don't care what
I'm just messing with your Peralta put
your hands down give me a hug baby
yes let's go Church let's go a member of
the commissioner selection committee is
coming in today to tour the precinct and
do some interviews would you mind
speaking with her of course here she is
I guess you don't have time to take off
those ridiculous suspenders what no Miss
Sumpter hello Captain I'm excited to
speak to your subordinates and learn
more about your management style
Sergeant Jeff is here Sergeant oh um I'd
rather not talk to a supervisor I was
hoping to interview one of your
detectives perhaps um
him yes you can interview detective
Hitchcock and I am completely fine with
that
I thought you went straight I did I'm a
high-end car broker now last week I
dropped off a Bugatti to the kid the
list from stranger things you meant
Dustin was he cool to him and the rest
of the gang hang out in real life you
know what no we are not
hostages you mean Pam and the two Bobs
they're not hostages Ernie race Jr I
gave him each 500 bucks on my own pocket
thanks again to hugging I'm sorry
officer are you friends with this
criminal no not really absolutely best
friend it's the layered relationship
pants friends Judy get over here
two years ago before I went straight I
stole the car from a drug dealer Martin
Holloway oh no Judy he's a bad guy I
know they had to do a job for him to pay
off my debt did you tell him about
Dustin I did he said he doesn't watch
stranger things oh this guy's worse I
know
all I need is for you too let him go so
he can arrange a drop of Halloween we
arrest Halloway save Judy's mom and Judy
turns himself in everything he told you
is alive why do you say he's lying
that's all negotiating is two Liars
lying to each other until one liar
stands too close to the window and gets
shot in the head
[Laughter]
the window plan is on no no no no
snipers to zero snipers take a nap the
nap plan is on it's nap time snipers
totally forgot about it
Charles sorry I'm a bit stressed Jason
and Jeff the guys I hired to work a
truck called in sick stop freaking out I
have the day off I can
stop as I please it's part of my charm
like an outdoor cat
absolutely I gotta turn myself in and
let Holloway kill my mama there might be
another way to get this done I'm taking
your negotiator Hospital
just do whatever he says my life is in
his hands
two kids your mask on so much fun oh man
you sounded really scary no no no it was
all you dude seriously you are a great
hostage you're a great hostage taker
what
what is Pam gonna think of this I've
been waiting for this moment for so long
I'm ready to negotiate
but it's me Dennis oh come on
I think we're ready for a practice
sandwich sounds good boss please call me
Chef that's funny
Chef yes Jeff see the cut is a little
slopey I want you to cut it straight
across no big deal I wonder the friends
that didn't come your co-workers gonna
come in still sloppy again
why don't you just take that knife put
it to my throat and finish the job do I
look like to you do I look like
Jake to you no not at all then why are
you trying to screw me
Jesus there you go thank you no slope
thank you I felt good because the knife
but you smushed the breath it's too
smushy
again Jesus bring it in
Doug Judy you're under arrest wait Rosa
stop Jake is helping me take down
Holloway you're the Frog and he's a
scorpion you're gonna help him across
the river in the end he'll sting you hey
stops fables it's a good story I know he
used to be a criminal and he's foolby in
the past and he is currently engaged in
criminal activity innocent until proven
guilty but I am doing it Rosa we have to
help her plus he agreed to turn himself
in when this is all over right Judy I
promise
this is left hand though there's a woman
here interviewing detectives as part of
the commissioner's selection process she
wants to talk to you what no how could
you let this happen I'm next calm down
man
we have one hour to teach you how to
behave like a human you're gonna my bear
lady man it's a my fair lady porn parody
oh my we've got our work cut out for us
you knew what you were walking into I'm
detective Michael Hitchcock nice job why
are your hands so wet trick question the
answer is disgusting so I shouldn't tell
her just don't have wet hands man
you look incredible you bet I do these
pants really flatter my dong
is there a Le Creuset Pat on your
registry by chance of course you can
cook and serve in them what's your color
of preference French gray or mineral
blue ah he'll betray but still get the
gift consider it gifted also it will be
my honor
sing at your wedding yeah I don't think
that's going to be possible you're
probably still going to be in jail damn
that's right I almost forgot no you
didn't one of my men should do it would
take two of your people three trips each
to hold this much food my guy's a pro
I've been carrying tea couches before
you were born son fine but I want to
know what's going on in there we're
putting a camera on him how much older
you're on camera no audio thought so
that's why I'm tied up Scully what are
pepper flakes will you calm down the
food's a diversion although Scully it is
crazy that you forgot the pepper flakes
[Music]
dude he's trying to escape there's no
way all units move on the ambulance now
hi there nice work Dennis just caught a
man having a medical emergency why was
there a sheet over his head couldn't
find his pulse yeah it's super weak
where is Doug Duty so glass Kelly put
the uniforms in with the pizza I keep
finding hidden pepperonis
I got you oh Garlic Knot okay let's ride
this is so illegal all right let's text
Holloway and set up the drop
the diamonds let's meet now we wait no
we wait
where's that shoe about to drop kind of
weird sitting silently in a private
karaoke room not singing yeah but we're
on a mission so you know gotta stay
focused true
come on
take a big breath till I get real high
drop a set for 5 p.m let's do this
totally although that is an hour and a
half from now and the drop point is
actually pretty close to here
[Music]
[Applause]
why are you making six sandwiches at
once it's more efficient the perfect
meatball sandwich is sauce exactly 70
seconds before being served to maintain
bread Integrity change in menu we're
serving soggy turds now get them while
they're wet okay
oh geez quit just like Jeff and Jason
did you told us they got sick they got
sick of hard work just like you two get
out don't ever cook in this town again
we're not chefs and you never will be
ouch is Hitchcock doing okay he's
bringing his hand to his face don't pick
your teeth it's gonna lick something off
his fingers oh no he's poking his chin
as if in thought
oh they're looking at us act natural
spreadsheet spreadsheet crime crime
freezing to presents
that idiot thought he could just walked
in here and do my job it's hard my first
50 jumpers 49 died they only talked down
one person no he jumped too but he
landed on this woman who broke his fall
she died but you can't count that
against me
I don't think he was a hospital
I was pretty good friends with that done
I ever tell you you look like the most
interesting man in the world
get that a lot
it does
what's up Miss Hollywood how you doing
shut up give me the diamonds man I guess
the no Small Talk policy starts at the
top come on come on come on come on
rocked up no no no not now I tracked
your phone oh damn you that's Halloween
we gotta arrest him Jake he's running
come on man only if I get to call her in
100 of the credit are you negotiating
right now always
let's do it Judy stay here okay
[Music]
yes
the resting Holloway is going to give me
a promotion and at the end of the day
that's what this is all about right well
that and getting a major drug lord off
the streets let me give you some advice
I don't care about that
Doug don't worry we'll get him at least
we have Holloway in the diamonds Doug oh
my god he has the diamonds doesn't he
[Music]
so many wedding pots though what's up
he did pick up in yours this is goodbye
forever no
I can't believe you used my love for
your mother against me love that you
love her
they could take my badge Judy I guess
Rosa was right I'm a scorpion sorry I
can't be the man you want me to be damn
it stop being so romantic now turn
around and come back to me you fool
Now's the Time where you tell me
everything's gonna be okay everything's
gonna be okay you don't know that Rosa
she said you really helped my candidacy
oh it's my pleasure sir you were so
professional I know I didn't even fart
once you're right I can hold it
you couldn't change for good nah too
much work but that's not how my fair
lady ends Eliza Doolittle doesn't go
back to her whole life my bear lady is a
little different it's not Eliza
Doolittle and Henry Higgins it's Eliza
do everybody and Leroy pipe oh
we don't need a recap thank you for your
help today anytime captain
nice got a five in on it my one at a
time system worked perfectly yeah it's
just making nanoboils meatball recipe
got me thinking a lot about her and let
me guess you realize she'd be ashamed of
how you acted no Nana Boyle was a
monster she once yelled at me so loud I
fainted
it's like her and you felt terrible can
you guys forgive me please of course
Charles it's like Jekyll and Hyde I
can't control when Nana comes out
oh they're still trying to decide on the
punishment for your actions they said
they could have Justified your tactics
if you come away with Holloway and the
Diamonds well there are some diamonds
you know the tops of engagement rings
diamond mines but yes I see check the
envelope you're looking at a suspension
maybe worse unless you can track down
Doug Judy and recover those diamonds can
they wait 12 months I usually run into
them about once a year
I've got this coupon for a private room
we already have a song cute FB
to cause you any troubles yeah well you
caused me a lot talking to a
pre-recorded video but it's cool I know
what you're saying I hear you in my
heart what am I doing here I feel the
same way you my best friend too
start a new life here in San Diego
stupid telling me where you are come on
man I know
San Diego
Airport
of original smoosh jams it's on the
table next to you along with a little
something else
French gorilla Crusade pot now look
inside it
hey men's the diamonds yes I cannot
believe you actually brought the
diamonds
coupon you got there it's for a full
hour in the private room
so
hey oh what's going on
well done it's like you and your sister
a relationship that kind of friendship
you and your sister get along like that
I think you and your sister are really
really adorable friends
you guys read each other really well you
guys are inseparable yeah
you and your sister always pulling
schemes off on me
she's a sweetheart
true
except for that scorpion side
you guys use the same bathroom
sometimes nice
it's a lot to yeah that's what I'm
talking about I'll invite you to see it
what'd you think of our two episodes I
liked them both I liked both episodes
what would you rank the first one
um let's see which ones do you like more
just please just go like 90 episodes so
far
just go over the two which one did I
like more yeah come on John oh man it's
so hard to choose I thought they were
both quality episodes and both made me
laugh before the second one for me Jesus
all right I mean it's always the most
fun when Doug Judy's around although I
did very much enjoy uh uh Jake and Kevin
together I thought that was a very fun
Dynamic however Doug Judy's a party it's
hard to resist the party
yes
yes it is affirmative
agreed and I guess I guess just thinking
back here and now uh the sub play I just
felt like in the safe house
it never quite escalated between their
Dynamic sure it didn't really feel like
it grew okay nor did it feel like it
really got much worse and they were they
were saying they're like
you know having a hard time or whatever
but they they always look like well kept
together and I was like you've been in
there for a while you're like going on
like 10 11 weeks right now and it just
kind of feels like you shut this all in
the same day that's absolutely fair and
while I liked more of Kevin I was a
little bit let down by I don't really
feel like much is really happened I mean
I like the plot of them possibly getting
a divorce or whatever but
um it was a little predictable how it
went too sure all absolutely you know
what you've convinced me this was yeah
John I'm right I'm always right even
when I'm wrong I'm right when you're
wrong my motto even when I'm out I'm in
that's what I say you're the Nick Fury
of being right yeah yeah yeah I know and
I mean you had good subplots in this one
having to tune up Hitchcock uh boil
going too far with the sandwich prep
yeah some good fun hijinks in between
the event
of kicking with Doug Judy the fun
negotiator situation I did like Rose's
hair though in the previous episode it
was a very fun subplot
um yeah I like the negotiator that
hasn't True Blood right I believe so
yeah he's a character I think he's the
sheriff in True Blood I think it's a cop
in True Blood that sounds kind of right
um I like the the gimmick of his
character it was funny yeah it's funny
but no there's just something really
refreshing about Craig T Robinson and uh
did I get the name right
does it does he put a t in there
sometimes you might be right Craig T
Nelson Craig T Nelson is the T Craig T I
I associate okay but I can't remember if
Craig Kilbourne was before Craig Fergus
Craig Ferguson yeah
Craig is what some people think my name
is if it's not Gary
isn't that funny it's either this one
letter swap or a two-syllable name
or there's Jenny Craig helps you lose uh
the weight you know that British
that's right
who she thinks she is
your life
I have no idea
for the joke lands yes
you think of another Craig I'll find out
if Jenny's not can I take it back all
right this is Jenny Craig real uh is
Jenny Craig still alive
wait was it just some British woman that
they had with the spokesperson or was it
Jenny Craig the woman the British woman
that's not Jenny Craig I was thinking of
who was the spokesperson
I'm talking about that British woman who
was always like on the commercials for
Jenny Craig
she was like an actual wait I remember
she was in like an episode of Friends
she's like a real actress she was like
an actress yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
Jenny Craig spokesperson it wasn't like
Kirstie Alley oh John
I think of the right the right weight
loss one or is it are you thinking of uh
what's the one where you count points
they used to do commercials all the time
was that Jennifer I don't think that was
Jenny Craig was it was it Weight
Watchers Weight Watchers
let me see you wait I'll get over here
it's important uh
let me see some face Jenny McCarthy no
I'm pretty sure it was Jay Craig type of
British spokeswoman okay God damn it
John Jenny Craig British spokesperson
I'll figure this out myself
right Kirsty alley was from before
um but Jenny Craig does still seem to be
alive she's 90 who have been the most
popular
actresses
was it Valerie Bertinelli spell what
does she look like uh her no
person or celebrities
for Jenny Craig in the 90s I'm gonna
laugh really hard if it turns out to be
Kirsty alley it's not Kirsty alley it's
a British woman all right
I think it was Jenny Craig
I mean Jenny Craig herself I think is
British maybe it was just Jenny Craig
oh no no Jenny Craig is not British he's
American
dumbass yeah she was born in Louisiana
who's Connie Stevens
comment below who Connie Stevens is
uh she's an actress
Connie Stevens British I don't remember
if she's British I don't know if my
memory is telling me anymore
nah nah don't worry about it we're ever
gonna find out it's okay we'll never but
um yeah
Ernie race Jr was here I know for all of
them yeah surprising his role from rush
hour too
how many security guards has he played
in his lifetime I don't know I don't
even know why he was here poor guy he
was on his way to like stardom Surf
Ninjas Ninja Turtles too oh yeah and
then he became and he was in The Rundown
when he fought Dwayne Johnson he was the
fast guy oh that's right he's like got a
career as a stunt man martial artist
yeah and then he's just like these one
random one lines what happened who did
he piss off in Hollywood I don't know
who's got who's Filipino
yeah no not really do you know kind of
career
he could be watching right now yeah oh
they reacted in episode 14. oh let
me watch can't wait to hear what they
have to say about it whatever you kick
my ass
oh dude we should set up that fight live
stream it what me you know heartbeat um
probably one punch would knock me out
one punch it's a really fast fighter
super fast and take advantage of it uh
yeah I know that's kind of just
surprising it was here uh but I love the
relationship between um Craig T Nelson
and uh Bill Hader yeah really one of
Cinema's finest I think that they have a
really great relationship their Father's
son Dynamic the next cage thing was fun
have you seen the Adams Andy Stamford in
cage SNL oh like in The Rage Cage where
you'd come on Weekend Update and stuff
when yeah when he did it right next to
Nicholas Cage yeah and they did it
together yeah funny oh I was there I saw
that live oh did you think so or at
least I've seen I think so I think I
don't know what Saturday love wants
barely remember it well during the Andy
Samberg days I would have actually like
caught episodes for real at some points
so
um but no I mean these these two were
good uh the Sheamus thing kind of got
resolved in a underwhelming factor too
that's something there's something about
that episode just like kind of
underwhelming so they're in a rush to
just kind of resolve it I like the fun
of the games but during the episode I
was thinking of like there were more
Stakes to the the
nephew or whatever yeah there's so many
more Stakes to that than yeah like that
was a I thought that was a much stronger
Works more exciting episode but I was
sitting there's a lot of there's a lot
of flat there's a lot of ideas and I'm
like in my head I'm like oh that's funny
but nothing's really like making me
really laugh out loud too much like the
crawling on the floor thing there's a
lot of funny ideas but a lot of it was
uh
was like I'm amused yeah I I I couldn't
help but wonder I mean I was enjoying
the episode certainly but I couldn't
help but but think about how they do
these you know multiple episode you know
arcs where it seems like some kind of
huge you know this is a really serious
situation that they're dealing with it's
it's outside of the normal range of
criminal operations usually up against
and so yeah I'm like I know the point of
this show isn't necessarily to do like a
big serialized dramatic Saga however I
am I was sitting there going part way
throwing okay so the way this is moving
I bet they're just going to wrap this up
in this episode and it is yeah like a
little less than satisfying because it
is like this could have really come to a
head but they they kind of just you know
sure found the exact right circumstances
to catch them and that's that yeah you
know it's not really yeah there's not
really much tension
but still Brooklyn nine nine still had a
fun time plenty of alcohol required
um there's still a good time as always
and uh yeah not my favorite of the
seasons no pretty good where would you
rank it among all 90 odd episodes all
right this is probably being like uh to
be like mid bottomed here good well I
don't think these episodes were
the last few have been really great and
this was like these were these were like
good but not the high standard I
expected Brooklyn nine-nine's quality
writing yeah I see what you mean you
know what I mean yeah it's my mission
impossible dead reckoning all over it no
no it's yeah you're just stuck in this
opinion this is the highest rated
episode
some people say they peaked here yeah
it's got a 106 audience ratings
um what are you gonna do alrighty guys
well thank you so much for being here
and um looking forward to more Brooklyn
nine nine I like doing them two at a
time yeah it's fun it actually feels um
more like when I watch comedies on my
own
usually not like I'm good with the one
just 20 minutes
yeah I want something I want to feel
like I had a comedic meal yeah
you should have done the two from the
beginning ah it's okay we're here now
we're here now now that we're well past
the halfway
alrighty guys thank you so much for
being here we'll talk to you all soon
peace out